S
ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THAT TANK OPERATOR IS ONE OF
THOUSANDS THAT ARE LIKE SITTING
DUCKS IN UKRAINE'S WIDE OPEN
EAST.
WE HAVE ANOTHER VIDEO.
YOU SEE A COLUMN OF RUSSIAN
TANKS BELIEVED TO BE IN EASTERN
UKRAINE.
THESE ROADS ARE STRAIGHT ROADS
RIGHT THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE,
DRIVING ALONG, SPOTTED BY
UKRAINIAN DRONES.
SERIES OF STRIKES TAKING OUT
THOSE TANKS ONE BY ONE ANOTHER
ALL THAT'S LEFT IS A CHARRED
GRAVEYARD TANKS STILL BURNING.
RUSSIA LOST ABOUT 10,000 TANKS
AND ARMORED VEHICLES IN THE LOSS
OF HUMAN LIFE CONTINUES TO MOUNT
WHICH IS WHY SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED TODAY STANDS OUT AS
ODD.
THE LEADER OF THE GROUP
ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT HE WILL NO
LONGER BE RECRUITING PRISONERS
TO FIGHT IN THE INVASION.
NOW THIS IS SIGNIFICANT IF HE'S
TELLING THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE THEY SENT MORE THAN
50,000 CONVICTS TO THE FRONT
LINES IN UKRAINE.
SO WHY WOULD HE NO LONGER BE
RECRUITING CONVICTS?
WELL, THE ANSWER IS UNCLEAR.
BUT THE SHIFT IN STRATEGY COULD
BE BLAMED ON THE MASS RUSSIAN
CASUALTIES, COULD BE BLAMED ON
TANK OPERATORS DRIVING OVER
THEIR OWN DEAD AND INJURED LIKE
RAG DOLLS AND THE CONVICTS IS NO
LONGER THERE.
RUSSIA IS SHAMING ITS YOUNG MEN
INTO FIGHTING.
THE FACE OF RUSSIAN STATE
TELEVISION, WE SHOW HER TO YOU,
IS NOW TELLING YOUNG MEN IT'S NO
BIG DEAL IF YOU DIE 30 YEARS
EARLY.
>> Translator: BUT THERE IS NO
CHANCE TO ESCAPE DEATH.
THE DIFFERENCE IN 10, 20, 30
YEARS IS REALLY NOT THAT BIG.
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE
UNIVERSE, IT'S NOT THAT BIG.
IT'S NOT CERTAIN WHICH IS A
BETTER WAY TO DIE.
>> INCREDIBLE, NO BIG DEAL IF
YOU DIE 30 YEARS EARLY, IN A
COUNTRY AVERAGE LIFE EXPECTANCY
IS 59.8.
THAT'S A SICK THING TO SAY.
IMAGINE THAT, ZERO DISREGARD FOR
HUMAN LIFE.
IN A MOMENT I'M GOING TO SPEAK
TO THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST A REGULAR HERE ON OUR
SHOW WHO HIS NEW REPORTING ON
HOW MANY RUSSIAN SOLDIERS ARE
NOW TURNING TO GOD.
IN FACT, HE SAYS RUSSIA IS NOW
NAMING BATTALIONS AFTER SAINTS
AND RUSSIAN MEDIA BIZARRELY
CLAIMS ONCE THE BATTALION NAME
GOT CHANGED PEOPLE STOPPED
DYING.
>>> FIRST, FRED PLEITGEN IS OUT
FRONT ON THE GROUND.
>> MERCENARIES IN BRUTAL BATTLES
AROUND BAKHMUT IN EASTERN
UKRAINE.
AMONG THE ASSAULT FORCE,
CONVICTS, CHARGING IN WAVES,
SUFFERING DEVASTATING LOSSES.
WAGNER PRAISES HIS GROUPS
BATTLEFIELD EFFICIENCY BUT NOW
IS SUDDEN ABOUT FACE.
WE HAVE COMPLETELY DISCONTINUED
THE RECRUITMENT OF PRISONERS
INTO WAGNER PMC, HE WRITES.
THOSE WHO WORK FOR US NOW ARE
FULFILLING ALL THEIR
OBLIGATIONS.
UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE RECENTLY
GAVE CNN ACCESS TO TWO CONVICTS
RECRUITED BY WAGNER WHO THE
UKRAINIANS CAPTURED ON THE FRONT
LINE.
THEY SAID THEY WERE SPEAKING
WITH US WILLINGLY BUT WE'RE
DISGUISING THEIR IDENTITY FOR
THEIR OWN SAFETY.
THEY WERE 90 OF US IN OUR FIRST
ASSAULT, HE SAID.
60 DIED IN THE FIRST ASSAULT
KILLED BY MORTAR FIRE.
A HANDFUL REMAINED WOUNDED.
THE MEN SAY THEY WERE CANNON
FODDER BUT RETREATING WAS NOT
ALLOWED.
WE WERE GIVEN THE TASK OF TAKING
A PLACE AND WE HAD TO TAKE IT AT
ANY COST, HE SAYS.
WE COULDN'T RETREAT WITHOUT
ORDERS BECAUSE IF WE DIDN'T
COMPLY, WE WOULD BE KILLED.
FOUR MONTHS PERSONALLY WENT TO
RUSSIAN JAILS WITH HIS OFFER
EVEN FOR MURDERS AND RAPISTS,
FIGHT SIX MONTHS IN UKRAINE, AND
IF YOU SURVIVE, YOU'LL BE FREE.
ONLY A HANDFUL IN MY UNIT CAME
FOR MONEY, HE SAYS.
MOST CAME BECAUSE THEY HAD LONG
JAIL SENTENCES.
BUT THERE WERE ALSO SOME WHO HAD
ONLY 12 DAYS OF THEIR SENTENCE
REMAINING AND THEY WENT ANY WAY.
THE UKRAINIAN BELIEVE WAGNER SO
FAR SENT AROUND 50,000 CONVICTS
TO UKRAINE, WITH A MASSIVE
ATTRITION RATE AS HIGH AS 80%
KILLED, WOUNDED, CAPTURED OR
DESERTED.
PREGOSHEN SEEMS UNFAZED BY THE
LOSSES.
THEIR CONTRACTS HAVE ENDED.
THEY'RE GOING HOME, HE JUST
SAID.
BUT WHY WOULD PREGOSHEN SAID HE
CHANGE WHAT HAD HE FEELS IS A
WINNING FORMULA?
HE DIDN'T GIVE ANY REASON BUT
ONE POSSIBILITY MIGHT BE THAT
THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTRY HAS
SIDELINED WAGNER AND IS NOW
FULLY TAKING CONTROL OVER
RECRUITING CONVICTS, AT LEAST
THAT'S THE VIEW OF PRISONER
ADVOCACY GROUP RUSSIA BEHIND
BARS.
>> Translator: PRISONERS ARE
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH.
SOME RUSSIAN SOLDIERS MIGHT NOT
LIKE FIGHTING ALONGSIDE
PRISONERS IN TRENCHES, BUT
THERE'S BIG POTENTIAL AND IT'S
EASY TO RECRUIT MASSES.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA'S DEFENSE
MINISTRY DIDN'T REPLY TO OUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT, BUT
UKRAINIAN MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
BELIEVES THERE IS A POWER
STRUGGLE UNFOLDING.
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES IS GOING TO
BELITTLE CH PREGOSHEN'S ROLE HE
SAYS SO HE CANNOT STRENGTHEN HIS
POSITION IN THE KREMLIN
HIERARCHY.
NOW, OF COURSE, ERIN, THERE
COULD BE VARIOUS OTHER REASONS
WHY YEVGENIY SAYS HE WILL NO
LONGER RECRUIT CONVICTS FOR THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
MIGHT SIMPLY BY RUNNING OUT OF
PEOPLE WILLING TO GO EVEN IN
RUSSIAN JAILS.
OF COURSE, WORD IS SPREADING
THAT THE ATTRITION RATES FOR
WAGNER ARE EXTREMELY HIGH.
COULD ALSO BE A SHIFT IN
STRATEGY BY THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
THAT MAKES THAT TYPE OF WARFARE
LESS CONDUCIVE T